- I wanna discuss a serious
topic with you as well.
So we're seeing protests
against anti-Asian violence.
And I just wanna know your thoughts on it.
- It's actually, what's been
happening has been incredible.
I think a lot of, a lot of
people have been reaching
out to me and wondering how
they can help, what they can do.
And I love to post tangible
things that people can do
'cause there's all sorts
of performative activism.
- Mmhmm.
- I think we just came out
of a long line of politicians
that put a target on Asian people's backs
by calling it the China virus.
And so people are seeing Asian
people out on the street.
I automatically think of like
when my mom's without me,
how do people look at her?
How do people treat her?
A lot of mothers and
fathers are being targeted
around the country and it is so,
it's so obvious to me what the motive is.
It's not, it doesn't seem to
be obvious to the politicians
out there that are saying like,
we're not quite sure of the motive.
But I think we know what it is
and if people can just
reach out in any way
to support the Asian-American community.
AAPI in general, there's Stop AAPI Hate
which is a wonderful
organization to donate to.
And an organization
called 18 Million Rising
is really incredible.
But also support, it's little things
like supporting Asian owned
businesses around you,
supporting your local China Town.
I mean these things are disappearing
quicker than we know it, and
soon they're gonna be gone,
and it's heartbreaking to me, so.